. So I have sadly just terrible news for you
today.
The United States trajectory of new cases
since we got our first hundred cases is the
worst in the world, bar none.
OK.
So I'm going to go through a few bits of data
with you today.
The way things are going, we are going to
be in a nightmarish dystopia that will make
this week and the hundreds of deaths this
week not seem that bad.
So before we look at this, I want to first
update you on the official numbers.
Understand that it's been an hour since I
grabbed these numbers.
So they've already changed.
They've already gotten worse.
But as of probably by the time you watch or
listen to this, a few hours ago, as of this
morning, the United States had sixty eight
thousand official cases.
Sixty eight thousand official cases.
The real number of cases, of course, is probably
between 4 and 20 times that.
So we're looking at anywhere from, you know,
two hundred and seventy five thousand cases,
1.4 million cases we really don't know because
we aren't testing.
We are we are backlogged on testing.
And a lot of people aren't being tested at
all.
So we just don't know.
But the official case number there it is in
terms of the states.
New York currently has just under half of
the whole country's cases.
Other hot spots are New Jersey, California
seeing a big increase.
Washington state has had a lot of cases.
They are getting it under control there.
It's spiked earlier in Washington, as many
of you know.
And then you've got a bunch of states right
around 2000 official cases, Michigan, Florida,
Illinois, Massachusetts, Louisiana.
And then you've got another tier in Georgia,
Texas, Pennsylvania, Colorado at every state
has some cases at this point.
Now, of course, the United States is a different
sized country than others.
We're a large country geographically.
We're also a large country in terms of population.
We've got about three hundred and forty million
people here with enough land area here.
You essentially have states that both in geographical
size and in population can be bigger than
many individual European countries.
So what we need to be looking at, just the
case numbers don't tell us that much.
We need to look at the trajectory.
How quickly are cases and deaths increasing
in the United States?
When we look at that rate, when we look at
how we are tracking.
One thing that we look at is after we got
our first hundred cases, meaning once you
get 100 hundred cases is when you know this
is going to be an issue and you've got to
start doing stuff.
We look at after 100 cases have been reached.
How quickly have the numbers gone up on this
chart that we're putting up for you, which
I will describe a steeper curve means a faster
increase in cases.
So when you look, I've highlighted certain
lines to make this easier to read.
Cases in the United States have increased
more quickly than they did in Spain.
And more quickly than they did in Italy.
Italy is one of the most disastrous and tragic
situations around the world.
Our cases are increasing more quickly than
that.
And since about day 19, after hitting one
hundred cases, we even passed China's level
of increase, which initially had absolutely
cartoonishly disastrous numbers.
So the point is, we started later in that
other countries started seeing case growth
sooner than the United States in absolute
terms in February instead of in March.
But in terms of the speed at which cases are
increasing here in the United States, we are
doing worse than just about every country.
And the implications are disastrous if this
doesn't change.
And remember, 30 states aren't doing a damn
thing to make it slow down in another 10 days.
We are going to have an unconscionable number
of cases, an insane number of people hospitalized.
The medical system will be overwhelmed.
Deaths are going to skyrocket and hospitals
are actually already overwhelmed.
Some of the stuff Trump is talking about,
you know, ad hoc FEMA facilities bringing
a hospital ship up to New York City.
It takes weeks or longer to get that stuff
online.
So right now, while we're working on a vaccine
that's a year away, we're testing large clinical
trials, looking at anywhere from four to there's
really 30 or 40 different possible treatments
that are being explored.
The only tool we have right now is physical
distancing and staying the hell home.
And Donald Trump is starting to talk about
ending it on April 12th and filling churches
in large parts of the country.
So just do the math as to whether this makes
sense.
Meanwhile, Germany while dealing with lots
of cases there.
Keeping their death rate very, very low, and
when this started and the death rate was low
in Germany, we thought, well, Germany just
hasn't gotten that many cases yet.
The more serious cases are going to develop.
The death rate is going to go up.
Germany now has nearly 40000 confirmed cases
and only 222 deaths as of this morning.
Still tragic.
Two hundred and twenty two deaths, but it's
a death rate of about half of one percent.
That's very good compared to what we're seeing
in a lot of other countries.
The question is why?
One thing is their medical system is not yet
overwhelmed.
Number two, they started testing earlier.
So they have probably a closer to accurate
assessment of the number of cases.
Still not totally accurate, but closer than
the United States.
We know.
And Dr. Isaac Bogong told us earlier this
week, the outcomes are much better when the
system is not overwhelmed.
The earlier and the more that you test so
you can quarantine people, the better you're
going to do in terms of preventing that medical
system from becoming overwhelmed, were overwhelmed.
This is the point of social distancing.
This is the point of flattening the curve,
given 100000 cases in a month versus one hundred
thousand cases in six months.
You prefer it in six months because it keeps
the hospitals less full and therefore the
outcomes are better.
Meanwhile, we have a president who wants to
go in the other direction and let her rip
on April 12th.
I'm getting now dozens of e-mails daily from
people in the Netherlands saying we're fully
shut down until I think they said June 1.
Canada saying we know our even our our briefings
from Trudeau, he's by himself versus Trump
still talking about social distancing.
And up on a dais with a crowd of people in
a room full of reporters, people are e-mailing
me saying, I'm so sorry, David, that you're
dealing with a country that is doing seemingly
the opposite of what many other countries
have figured out.
It's it's very, very bad.
Let's take a quick break.
After the break, we will talk about who do
Americans trust when it comes to the virus?
You might be surprised or maybe not.
We'll also talk about five G conspiracy theories
exploding now that they can be interlinked
with Corona virus.
Those
stories
and more coming up right after the break.